you know on the show as I mentioned
everyone insults your character Jonah
everyone insults him and the writing of
the insults is so creative
but it's occurred to me sometimes that
it'd be one thing if they were insulting
just your personality mm-hmm
okay because that's not your personality
that's the character you're playing but
a lot of times nothing insult your
physicality and then I've thought to
myself because you seem like such a nice
guy and such an Italian - doctor cuz I
don't forget you ever feel insulted when
they're making fun of what is what is
really your body yeah you will you yes
yeah you try to cover it I mean we got
into comedy because we have removed all
feeling and emotion from ourselves those
do not exist at ingo exactly yeah so
that is why we are saying here yes but
there are you think it's gonna you think
it might be the flowery ones when you're
called a sentient enema that that might
be the one that hits the heart was that
a real one sentient and I was called a
sentient Mio enema I was called a the
world's largest single-cell organism
right really it's the simple and clean
ones I was at one point there's a moment
where a woman is looking at a video of
me in uh like not a control group what
do they call it a um like a test study
like a test done of Mercia 'ls and she
just thinks about it for a moment and
goes he's just the wrong shape and
that's just so all-encompassing yeah it
has nothing to do with personnel right
there was one at some point my fiancee
on the show who treats me terribly it's
mentioned something about my hips at
just his hips are weird
yeah and I remember that in hice in
middle school I hit this this this thing
this memory in middle school that I wore
sort of ill-fitting pants that were they
very well may have been women's pants
let's assume they were women and if you
need adult shoes to go with those pants
and I think wait that's a different show
we had remember that Andy on Tuesday of
course we were talking to Andy pretty
much went on and on about how he likes
to shop for adult women's shoes but
anyway again Tuesday so much crazy stuff
has happened since then the apparently
these pants it just accentuate it was an
awkward teenagers hips and it became a
thing I think a thing for many years
after and there I was like a full grown
adult man with a family of his own and I
realized I had not gotten over somebody
making fun of my hips from middle school
right stuff like that it's way down
there it's in your hard drives oh yeah
someone says something mean about you
when you're six or seven or eight it's
there forever it's there forever now you
have a job where they're digging that
stuff up and saying it to you thing on
television and people love it so I guess
I have to keep going yeah what would you
say is there have you been
has anyone ever yelled and insult at you
on the street that they got from the
show the most the most common one is
Jolly Green bass I think because
obviously because of my height and I
think the alliteration people like that
Jolly Green it's catchy it yeah yeah
yeah but here's the thing if you I mean
like before I was on a television show
like when I just lived in Los Angeles
and I would be at the grocery store and
I would see somebody from a TV show that
I liked like as exciting I was like a
cool thing it felt like living in LA and
I would say maybe once I said something
and this is just like like a tip a PSA
from me to the audience if the character
that you like has a semen related
nickname and you throw it out at the
grocery store you're a stranger talking
to another stranger about semen yeah and
I just think that that's the place you
want to avoid generally so just pick one
of the other non semen related jokes or
nicknames right no with that so people
have been yelling that at you like in in
grocery stores yeah that's not right
they shouldn't do that must be tough to
be a porn
actor you think who admits to
recognizing them though not me
whispering soft button I say I've read
your work
you